so it's recently been brought to my
attention that um by people that I've
dated that one of the biggest barriers
to dating me is that it seems as though
I always put you first
and that
um you are always a priority
and
um and I feel like I don't know how to
not
like
like put you first
so what are your thoughts on that I
think okay another thing is I feel like
I've been groomed
you you grew my hair dog
I feel like I've been like hard like
programmed to just like
be at your beck and call like always
and I don't know how you did it but you
did it
you know
in any every any given moment in any
City
there are parties going on the same
night okay
some parties are better than others
and there's some parties
are the parties you want to be in
that's all I have to say about that
so you can [__] with these little
parties right all you want right
but if you want to go to the gala ah
you're the cow the Met Gala he's the Met
Gala
this is the party baby
and um your little parties you know what
I mean yeah they have muscles they drive
trucks they make jewelry they make
jewelry or what yeah they do yeah they
do right they make jewelry right they're
clean you know I mean they look good on
the inside right
but it's not this party dude you know
this party is chaos you know I mean it's
Doctor Strange plus you know I mean it's
like it's the Multiverse it's
multi-multivar right it's like there's
things going on you know what I mean and
it's like you're gonna miss it so you
can go to your regular party with the
beer or you know I mean you know I mean
and the little dj this and that but if
you want [__] Cosmic [__]
experiences and um yeah
you gotta you gotta buy a ticket man and
you bought the ticket and you know what
you're the smart one
I don't know
what I don't know I just bought whatever
this was yeah maybe I'm like you're
right
yeah
listen man you know I mean hello hi hi
to him right now you know
but my point is I'm not the listen all
right you can do it I don't I don't ask
you to put me in first
you think I ask you
um or is the key he doesn't even have to
I I think that he no longer has to he
could just call me and be like some this
happened and immediately I'm like I got
it yeah but then don't do that because
if I say I'm sick then you're you're oh
you gotta drink lots of water and you
tell me what I need to be doing right so
don't do that from now on don't no
I woke up and you know I opened my eyes
but then I was like are they closed
because I'm blind I'm on my way see
that's okay no don't do that don't do
that oh no yeah
yeah you're not supposed to you [__]
see that's what I'm saying you gotta get
trained she did the fake scenario yeah
you did the scenario wrong no this is
what I'm saying do you know all right
I'm going blind it doesn't matter you
got to let it go man you gotta go you
gotta figure it out blind maybe could
she help with is that too much that's a
lot something more more
um it's blind too much you got into
um someone uh ran into your brand new
Audi recently no I don't want to do that
one because it's too real okay but who
did you call
you and then and Andrew and then I
immediately right